la conseillère du premier ministre jean
castex mayada boulos a un temps fait du
lobbying pour l'arabie saoudite
elle était alors durant quatre ans et
jusqu'en 2020 directrice générale
adjointe de la grande agence havas
interrogé par mediapart qui n'ont pas
échappé ses anciennes fonctions
la conseillère s'est défendue de toute
mission sur le domaine régalien où la
diplomatie
il s'agissait de faire connaître un site
historique et culturel ses monuments et
les activités notamment la découverte du
désert et la création à venir d'un musée
que la région pouvait offrir aux
touristes étrangers dans le futur mayada
boulos assurer la promotion du site
archéologique des lula elle explique ne
pas avoir oeuvré pour le compte de ryad
mais pour une fondation appartenant au
prince mohammed bin salman un site
stratégique aussi pour la france puisque
le prince avait décidé d'y investir 50
milliards de dollars pour attirer les
touristes internationaux et la france
est l un des partenaires et des
aménageurs de ce site exceptionnel
une merveille tu ne vais pas oublier aux
médias la réputation qu'ils accolent au
royaume
sept petites aspérités au milieu du
lumineux cv de mayada boulos dans les
cabinets ministériels et les grandes
agences de communication avait été
débusquée par le magazine marianne en
mai 2019
elle aurait été pressenti pour remplacer
le communicant sylvain fort à l'elysée
des proches du dossier interviewé par
l'hebdomadaire ont expliqué à marianne
qu'elle aurait décliné pour des raisons
d'organiser et non en raison de son
ancienne collaboration matignon at il
été perturbé par cette mission les
services du premier ministre n'ont pas
répondu à nos sollicitations sur la
question en tout cas on s'aperçoit que
ce n'est pas toujours mal vue d'avoir
travaillé pour une puissance étrangère
suivez mon regard l'arabie saoudite
reste un client important de la france
notre pays étant l'un de ses
fournisseurs d'armes les plus importants
dont certaines sont suspectés de servir
dans le conflit avec le yémen
mais revenons au coeur du sujet l'arabie
saoudite est accusée de bombarder des
populations civiles yéménite ou d'avoir
caché le corps démembré d'un journaliste
dans une valise en même temps les
agences de lobbying dans différentes
parties du monde présente les atouts du
royaume
elle ne s'en sont pas toutes trop venté
msl la filiale de bruxelles ouest de
publicis chargé de cette communication
n'a pas déclaré le contrat avec son
encombrant client sur le registre de
transparence des activités de lobbying
mais cela ne les a pas empêchés de
travailler
réseaux sociaux organisation de
conférences l'observatoire européen du
lobbying le corporate europe observatory
a noté quels objectifs de transformation
du discours officiels saoudiens étaient
à l'oeuvre comme la promotion de la
popularité d'un mohamed ben ça
man réformateur la volonté de faire
oublier les atteintes aux droits humains
en focalisant sur des avancées des
droits des femmes telles que la conduite
ainsi la teneur des articles concernant
l'arabie saoudite a évolué positivement
ces dernières années on découvre des
sujets sur le paris-dakar finances est
accueilli par le royaume sur les talents
de réformateurs du prince sans oublier
le fabuleux site d'al oula mise à
l'honneur par l'inénarrable jack lang
qui lui a réservé une exposition à
l'institut du monde arabe qui préside al
oula merveille d'arabie je vous parle
d'un site encore presque inconnu c'est
un site à la beauté fulgurant car le
lobbying cible aussi les politiques
certains parlementaires français ont
ainsi été invités à visiter le centre de
commandement militaire de la coalition a
riyad qui supervise la guerre au yémen
certaines personnalités politiques
françaises ne ménagent pas leurs efforts
pour préserver leurs relations avec le
royaume wahhabite par exemple rachida
dati et michèle alliot-marie membres de
la délégation du parlement européen pour
les relations avec la péninsule arabique
ont refusé en mai 2010huit de voter une
résolution condamnant les violences
sexistes en arabie saoudite
décidément mohammed bin salman peut
compter sur de nombreux soutiens
français qui ronronne jusque dans les
parlements et les ministères